okay so in this presentation we're gonna
go over the genetic inheritance pattern
known as autosomal dominance and here we
have a man and a woman let's keep this
family friendly and let's say this is a
hill husband and wife and let's say for
now the husband has an autosomal
dominant disorder and I'm gonna make his
genotype this capital D lowercase D
heterozygous and you'll see why I chose
that in a little bit
the mother I'm gonna have her healthy
and so her genotype is gonna be
homozygous recessive to lowercase DS
well this is kind of giving us a clue as
to the pattern of autosomal dominant
dominance look at the key if a genetic
disorder is autosomal dominant that
means that the disorder is dominant and
having the healthy allele is recessive
and when we look at the possible gene
combinations when when it when when we
look at a punnett square you notice
there's four parts to a punnett square
that's because there are four possible
allele combinations that a child might
inherit for instance the child might
inherit a capital D from dad and a
lowercase D from mom and this person
would be heterozygous another possible
combination would be a lowercase D from
each parent this would be called
homozygous recessive a third possible
combination might be a capital D from
the father and a lowercase D from the
mother this would be called heterozygous
and the last possible combination again
would be to lowercase D's one from each
parent and these are the four genetic
allele combinations right here these are
the four possible genotypes and in the
case of autosomal dominance you're often
going to hear that if one parent has an
autosomal dominant disorder that they're
gonna have a 50/50 chance of having a
child with the disease so let's go into
this in more detail
so first of all what's an autozone well
autosomal-dominant
is the topic of this presentation so
what's an autosome first of all here is
a karyotype and if we look at the
definition of an autism and autism by
definition is a non sex chromosome that
would be chromosomes 1 through 22
chromosome 1 2 3 4 so in this karyotype
I'm numbering the chromosome pairs we've
all inherited 2 chromosome 15s and 2
chromosome 21s 2 chromosome threes these
are called
the autosomes these are the non sex
chromosomes if you if you recall
chromosome 23 could be the XX for a
female or an XY for a male so chromosome
23 are the sex chromosomes autosomes are
all the others and so what we're gonna
look at our autosomal disorders
autosomal disorders our disorders that
are caused by a gene that happens to be
located on one of these 22 chromosomes
now you might be more familiar with
autosomal recessive disorders these are
the these are the disorders that kind of
follow the rules and patterns that
Gregor Mendel discovered when he was
experimenting with pea plants and then
these disorders an individual must
inherit two copies of the allele one
copy of the allele from the father one
from the mother in order to be affected
so I have that little key in the lower
left hand corner autosomal recessive is
when healthy is dominant and the
disorder is recessive and so here we
have an outline of a male and female and
their child well if the child inherits
one dominant allele from father from the
father and one dominant allele from the
mother the child is gonna be healthy if
the disorder is autosomal recessive of
course there's another possible
combination perhaps the father will pass
on a dominant allele perhaps the mother
will pass on a recessive allele but if
the disorder is
excessive the child's gonna be healthy
because of that capital each making the
child healthy and so with an autosomal
recessive disorder the only way to have
the disorder is to inherit one recessive
allele from the father and a second
recessive allele from the mother now the
child would have the disorder
if the disorder was autosomal recessive
so in autosomal recessive which he might
be more familiar with healthy is
dominant I like to use H's when I do my
punnett squares that's kind of the style
and format that I use you don't have to
use H but whatever letters are gonna use
they have to be capitalized if we're
talking healthy autosomal recessive
healthy is dominant and that means that
the vertice the disease whatever the
disease is is recessive
examples of recessive autosomal
recessive diseases cystic fibrosis is an
example of an autosomal recessive
disorder here and this is a disorder you
may have heard of where it affects the
lungs probably most severely it causes a
buildup of mucous and ultimately greatly
shortens the life span the life
expectancy of the sufferers and the
reason this is called an autosomal
recessive disorder again the gene that
causes cystic fibrosis is on chromosome
7 albinism you may have heard albinism
is where a person lacks the certain skin
pigments and so they often have a very
white pale appearance to their skin
sometimes they have visual defects the
more sensitive to sunlight well this is
also an autosomal disorder because the
gene that causes albinism is on
chromosome number 11 so you have to
inherit one chromosome number 11 with a
defective gene from from the mother and
another chromosome 11 with the defective
gene from the father and the last one to
mention is a disorder PKU
phenylketonuria it's a buildup of an
amino acid and ultimately it can cause
seizures and intellectual defects but
this gene that causes PKU is
found on chromosome 12 in order to have
the disease PKU because it's autosomal
recessive you have to inherit two copies
of the allele one from the chromosome 12
from your mother one from the chromosome
12 from your father well what what this
carrier type shows again chromosome 23
is not an autosome chromosome 23 are the
sex chromosomes so if there are diseases
on the X or the y chromosome we call
them sex linked one that you might have
heard of is a bleeding disorder called
haemophilia haemophilia is where a
person can have a very minor injury but
they could have severe bleeding and so
this is an example of a sex linked
disorder but we're gonna stick with
autosomes I just wanted to bring up the
difference really quick so now let's
move on to autosomal dominance after all
that is the topic of this of this video
with autosomal dominant it's a little
different in order to suffer from an
autosomal dominant disease you only need
to inherit one copy of the disorder one
copy of the allele and so when you look
the it's been flipped the disease is
dominant where any kind of capital H
will give you the disease whether you're
homozygous dominant or heterozygous and
therefore healthy is recessive so if I
put that key back in the lower left hand
corner you can see that the the rules
the pattern of autosomal dominance have
flipped and so if we put our our man
woman and child back if a child in here
it's one capital H from the father one
capital H from the mother this used to
be a healthy child if the disease is
autosomal recessive the child will be
healthy but what we're looking at now
our autosomal dominant disorders and
because the the disease is dominant this
individual would have the disorder
another combination might be if the
child inherits a capital H from the
father and the lowercase H from the
mother the child is still going to have
a disorder even though they have a
lowercase h healthy even though they
have one healthy allele they still have
one of the alleles for the disorder and
that's going to give the child the
disease because the disease is dominant
and so the only way to have a healthy
individual if you have a history of
autosomal dominance in the family is to
inherit not just one lower case H
healthy allele from the father but a
second lower case H healthy allele from
the mother that's the only combination
that will give a healthy individual and
that's the probably the biggest
difference between autosomal dominant
and autism or recessive examples of
autosomal dominant disorders probably
one of the more famous ones is
Huntington's disease it's a disease
caused by a gene located on chromosome
number 4 and you only have to inherit
one chromosome number 4 with the
defective gene and what it causes is in
the late 30s early 40s it causes brain
cells to die and the people start to
have these uncontrollable uncontrollable
muscle shakes and the picture shows the
folk singer by the name of Woody Guthrie
who's saying this land is your land this
land is my land and it's probably he's
probably the the more one of the more
famous persons to have had Huntington's
disease another example of a autosomal
dominant disorder is a brain disorder
called neurofibromatosis the gene that
causes this is on chromosome 17 you only
have to inherit one chromosome 17 with
the defective gene it causes a muscle to
earth excuse me it causes tumors to form
inside the brain so very serious and
another example of a autosomal dominant
disorder is abbreviated as simply FH
familial hypercholesterolemia and it's a
high cholesterol disorder that
ultimately can lead to cardiovascular
disease
so these three examples are all
characterized by being autosomal
dominant you only need to inherit one
copy of the allele to have the disease
let's go over some story problems to see
if we can solve these genetic problems
now so let's go over a couple practice
problems just to remind ourselves in
autosomal dominant the disease is
dominant so there's two possible
combinations a person could have in
order to have the disease now in the
story problem the disease is dominant
and healthy is recessive so one of the
things one of the problems you're going
to be faced with is if you're told that
a person has a disease you have to
figure out are they capital H capital H
homozygous dominant or are they capital
H lowercase H heterozygous and when it
comes to autosomal dominant one of the
deciding factors for you will be the age
of the person who has the disease like
it says in the notes homozygous dominant
individuals they don't survive very long
they have such a severe form of the
disease that it usually takes their life
at a very young age but if the person's
heterozygous they can live into their
adulthood years so watch this story
right here Paul has a disease called
familial hypercholesterolemia and his
wife Stacey is healthy the two of them
have three children and after the
testing the middle child is the only one
who's healthy so Paul has the disease
and he's married with three children
that implies right there that Paul is in
his adulthood years the story never
tells me whether or not Paul is capital
H capital H or capital H lowercase H the
story never tells me but because Paul is
in his adulthood eep adulthood years
married with three children he has to be
heterozygous so let me set up a punnett
square Paul fir is the square and Staci
is the circle squares represent male
and circles represent females and I'm
gonna make three branches one branch for
each child
I made the children boy boy girl square
square circle you can make the children
any gender you wish the gender of the
child is not very relevant in
determining the genotype and phenotype
of everyone here
well the story tells me that Paul has
the disease so I'm gonna color in his
square and the story tells me that only
the middle child is healthy so I'm gonna
color in the other two children because
when you color in a circle and square
that implies they have the disease I
know Paul's genotype has to be
heterozygous because he's married he's
got three children
he's clearly lived into his adulthood
years and the story also tells me that
Stacey is healthy so I'm gonna I now
know Stacey's genotype well now that I
know Paul and Stacey I can set up their
punnett square and when I set up their
punnett square all I have to do now is
fill in the four punnett squares and
once I've done that I can fill in the
inside of the punnett square just as a
reminder that anything with a capital H
in it the person's gonna have the
disease called familial
hypercholesterolemia but the two bottoms
part the two bottom squares are healthy
individuals so you can see there is a
1/2 chance there's a 50/50 chance that
every child will have the disease you
can see that in the punnett square right
now well look at the 3 children I know
that the child on the left the square on
the left is colored in they have to have
the disease that square in the middle is
not colored in the square in the middle
has to be healthy the square on the
right is excuse me the circle the circle
on the right is colored in that tells me
the circle on the right has the disease
so from very little information I was
able to figure out all of this but so
here's a our final practice problem that
we're gonna do together Huntington's
disease is a dominant disorder found on
chromosome 4 Betty and Marcus met
support clinic that they've been
attending to help them cope with the
knowledge of their illness
with Huntington's disease so both Betty
and Markus have Huntington's disease
they met one another while they were
trying to receive emotional support
because they knew that they had
Huntington's disease and now they want
to know the risk of having a healthy
child now that Betty is pregnant so I
have a square for Marcus and a circle
for Betty and I connected them and the
child is a boy perhaps and if you want
to make the child a girl go right ahead
well I'm gonna color in the square in
circle of Marcus and Betty because they
each have the disease now they have to
be heterozygous because clearly they are
of adulthood years there they're at the
age to marry and have a child if they
were if either of them were homozygous
dominant they would not have lived this
long into their life they have to be
heterozygous so now that I know Betty
and Marcus are heterozygous I can fill
in the punnett square and when we do we
kind of have some sad news in this
punnett square look at the punnett
square in the top left hand corner
that's the severe version of the disease
there's a 1 in 4 chance that child could
be born with a severe form of the
disease you can see that there's two
punnett squares that have the
heterozygous combination and there's
only a one out of four chance that that
child will be healthy so there's some
fairly depressing news here so we can
see what we can see that the probability
is is really not on their side in this
example here but this is what we've
learned is we've learned how to
calculate and make predictions and so go
ahead and pause the video here and I
hope this was helpful as we go about our
understanding of genetics pause the
video and try to answer some of these
questions if you're in my biology class
bring your answer to me on a separate
sheet of paper I'd be happy to check
them for accuracy good luck